foreign
[Music]
I do want to review this my new tick
tocker of the week
yeah although I don't really know if we
can Well here here's the thing how does
Adam feel about all these posts we're
making about them
this one's not about him no but I just
mean you know has he hit you up recently
no I looked today because I was like
I did feel a little bit bad after last
week yeah because I was like now it's
like been a couple weeks in a row yeah
and we did you know they we watched the
entirety of the cooking one yeah
and we kind of harped on every little
thing yeah including the jaw hinge so
I've been watching his new [__] to see
if he's still jaw hinging which he is so
you know maybe he didn't like take it to
heart yeah
so but like you know the ones we've been
doing have been kind of tongue-in-cheek
you know right I am a fan of his right
yeah but like this one I I wanted to do
like a serious one okay this is an
artist because you actually hate this
person no no I see like I I really like
Siri says in like this is an artist that
I appreciate I wanted to not that I
don't appreciate Adam but I'm saying
this is like I think this guy has like
real talent
and I wanted to what
okay this is sounding very bad
in regards of what I think about Adam
I'm not saying Adam doesn't have talent
I'm saying in the traditional sense
Adam's Talent isn't very obvious that's
like why do people like this guy we
don't know
man I'm just digging myself into a
deeper hole yeah dude did you want to
excavator for that the thing is I'm
trying to be nice
but it's hard
I'm just saying it's hard to say how
much I like this person without negging
this other person yeah okay
I'm not trying to diss at him by any
means
I'm saying his the reason why we like
him isn't as obvious as this okay this
is like an artist in the traditional
sense of like you know right a good
musical artist right okay right can you
play the landslide one please
[Music]
foreign
do you see what I mean yep it's moving
play the next one
but you don't know all this stuff you
put me through
man this feels so 90s like late 90s
early 2000s and it's like
it's got that texture to it I know right
it's like vintage
you know it's everything it's just the
bleached hair it's the weak mustache
it's the and I don't say that in a
derogatory way I just mean like it's
it's a vague mustache yeah you know and
then just the crooning
like this actually doesn't sound bad to
me I could hear this on the radio in
2000 and like 99 yeah like I hear this
one what do you mean it actually doesn't
sound bad I didn't you put me through
I didn't link this because it sounded
bad sure poetry
I see what you're saying though actually
yeah
I feel like it is kind of uh what's the
band like like is it like Smashing
Pumpkins or something what
they're about to kill you for saying
that wait who is who is they're fans
know the band smashing like pumpkins fan
the smashy Pumpkins band is gonna
[__] find your address and murder you
because you said you think they're gonna
see that yeah okay like that I'm trying
to like what who would be a good
reference I guess uh for a late 90s
early 2000s no [__] Matchbox 20 or
something that's not even really it
official just just Tatum just yeah is it
just Tatum the son follow me just just
Tatum just yet just just Tatum yeah
singer spiritual guide God's child uh-oh
what are you throw that little God's
child in there
that's like a little bit of the thirst
trap for you know
the religious ones oh okay yeah you know
when [__] boys are like John 3 16 yeah
yeah that's just so a good Christian
girl can swipe over and be like oh my
God yeah so yeah you're I've piqued your
curiosity oh 100
one there you go 16 000. it's one of his
reels has like a [__] ton of views I
think it was the Fleetwood Mac one yeah
because people are into it you know the
crooning it's good bro it works speaking
of it what is crooning is that it's like
I don't know look at the definition
crooning isn't that like when you turn a
raccoon into into Chrome
foreign
voice especially in a Sentimental manner
okay so it's not crooning at all I was
completely wrong about that
famous crooners oh I'm completely wrong
okay crooning is now what else it's just
that uh
that sounds more like a Corona in my
defense yeah it kind of does that sound
more like oh yeah that that word it's
not you know that doesn't sound like
crooners no no yeah
that's true yeah
whining I I equate crooning to whining
oh a little Taylor Swift
[Music]
the [__] says hashtag Flagstaff and I
would expect nothing less
from Flagstaff
yeah totally as Flagstaff right here
baby it's kind of the perfect yeah
perfect description yep for the swifties
this is a cameo request for My Boy Keith
and Megan
thank you for being awesome fans and
support the magical Inspirations Journey
inspirational journey I can't read
Taylor Swift gets a lot of hate herself
but her fans are the most loyal and look
at her now
dang so he equates her to a or he
equates himself to a Taylor Swift type
where he's like getting hate yeah maybe
but like the fans will he's got a he's
got an album coming soon
the original should we buy Cameo from
him
what would be funny for him to sing
um
oh
walk dude
Walkman
oh my God
come on we have to do it
okay yeah no I think it's the perfect
way to
what
I won't be cringing at him I'll be
cringing at us when he's doing Art
lyrics yeah I'll go whoa holy [__] we
wrote those
yeah he might do it better than us bury
Us Alive probably yeah yeah no just send
him the song
do the
I mean we don't have to do it on air
right now but we can do it after on air
we're live we're live
call in tell us what you think
we actually have an in studio live
performance today from Jess Tatum
so that's it that's my guy of the week
guy of the week that's fine I think
that's what you should rename it
yeah that's fair Kai of the week g-o-tw
no no no no don't spoil it for me man
no we just gotta how much is he 50 he's
59 bucks
yesterday's price rounds of slots yeah
to raise that money
yesterday's pricing today's price you
mean damn I woke up today and I just
knew I'm like I'ma suck this episode I'm
just gonna suck